[Musique]
saviez vous que les fruits surgelés sont
aussi bons voire meilleurs que les
fruits frais la raison les fruits sont
jolis sont surgelés au moment même de la
cueillette donc il ya un délai de
maximum 24 48 heures entre le moment où
ce que c'est que yi et laurence et
surgelés alors quels produits frais ont
une perte de nutriments au fur et à
mesure ce transport alors que les ventes
de fruits en conserves chute celle des
fruits surgelés elle est en pleine
croissance
mélanie on acheter sac l'épicerie et en
2015 on ne peut pas tout acheter le
reste c'est énorme la variété où je suis
un peu subjugué
ouais pourquoi vous pensez qu'il ya
cette oeuvre on dit aux gens de
consommer de plus en plus de fruits et
légumes
c'est une très belle alternative les
fruits surgelés pour plusieurs raisons
la disponibilité donc on a une très
grande variété prêt porte l'année
habituellement c'est moins cher si on
fait des comparatifs de prix là par 100
grammes c'est trois fois moins cher
environ le que le produit frileux petit
arrêt dans une usine d'ensachage de
fruits surgelés ou le mercure ce métier
sous le point de congélation
les bleuets c'est vraiment le produit
qui est le plus vendu en fruits surgelés
qu'ensuite les mélanges les mélanges de
petits fruits etc thereof
fondée en 2004 nature's touch est une
entreprise montréalaise qui a le vent
dans les voiles
on vend nos produits au canada aux
états-unis en asie la plupart des fruits
embellie 6 pouces en amérique du sud il
fruits mûrissent dans les champs
habituellement l'usiné sur relation est
située très très près du lieu culture en
quelques minutes à peine les fruits sont
ensuite surgelés à moins 30 degrés
celsius
voyez-vous sont surgelés et du helmand
donc ça veut dire que justement elles
sont pour coller une sont longues et
morceaux lorsqu'ils sont sur jolie ne
sort que dans le public on ouvrait ça
qu'on est capable de prendre les
morceaux loin à la fois
nathan il ya une liste d'ingrédients
autres que des fruits
oui on voit de temps à autre certains
additifs alimentaires glacis district
l'acide ascorbique est ce que les
additifs sont utilisés pour prévenir
l'oxydation
on sait que la bad en une fois qu'on les
peluches c'est qu'on a enlevé la pleure
on a brunni ce manque est très rapide
dont on ajoute à ce moment les additifs
pour éviter cette décoration
[Musique]
tendance forte au rayon des surgelés
offrir une grande diversité de fruits
on est habitué aux classiques phrase on
voit de plus en plus l'une très très
grande variété de produits comme
l'avocat qu'on voyait pas à 20 on voit
de la mort de coco qu'on voyait pas des
mandarines heureux loin sur jolie ont
deux des petits fruits du québec de plus
en plus d'encaisser les à mélenchon ce
très beau très rares comme produit en
fait et on le voit le slip retourner
chez eux qu'on est ici les baies
d'argousier ce lieu donc une gamme très
intéressante mais des produits un petit
peuple une seconde devant la grande
popularité des smoothie ce fait à la
maison coup à faire dans les commerces
et restaurants comme ici chez pure et
simple
l'industrie du surgelé a décidé de miser
sur de nouveaux produits
on voit même des petits sachets
individualisé qui contiennent les fruits
en différentes proportions le déjà pris
est parfaite pour un smoothie certain
que je vois que du suremballage à
certains moments
c'est voyez vous tester sans pesticides
donc une autre nouveauté donc ses
connaissances biologiques exactement
donc il ya un souci de plusieurs tests
on est rendu à en 250 et 500 testent le
savary de notre prise à l'eau et les
tests sont faits pour s'assurer que le
consommateur ne consomme pas de
pesticides lorsqu'ils consomment ces
produits là autre tendance marquée dans
cette industrie
le bio on sait que les consommateurs de
fruits biologiques qui se sont plus
soucieux de savoir la provenance des
fruits désirent en connaître davantage
au niveau de leur alimentation
donc ils s'informent un peu plus comme
par exemple les bleuets sauvages
biologique
on a vraiment mis sur le déçu que ça
provenait de la forêt boréale du québec
au québec
le bleu est le roi des fruits surgelés
le bleuet sauvage ça sera sûr j'allais à
pratiquement 100 pour ça il le bleuet
cultivé peut-être un ratio de 40% de 35
40 % aux surgelés et 60% on ferait sur
la géobiologie qui vient de chez nous
jean pierre senneville et à la tête du
regroupement québécois des producteurs
de bleuets sauvages leur qui se retrouve
dans les sacs des différentes compagnies
la compétition est forte compétition est
clair même plus fortes qu'elles étaient
cinq à dix à quinze ans parce qu'il ya
une explosion des preuves et des
productions avec ce soit au chili que ce
soit au maroc que ce soit en argentine
au mexique au pérou
dans certains sacs on trouve des bleuets
du québec mais pas toujours
mais l'eau est votre mot dire que
parfois si j'achète ce contenant là ça
se peut que ce soit aux bleuets n'ont
bleuets du québec qui parfois ça se peut
que ça le soit pas baca c'est pas
indiqué bleuets sauvages
on a déjeuné ce qu'est ce que ça
pourrait être des bleuets qui pourraient
provenir d'extérieur et bleu savage
biologique et accoucher de province
québécoise saguenay-lac-saint-jean et où
la côte nord d'haïti
si l'achat local est une priorité pour
vous sachez que c'est souvent un casse
tête de trouver la provenance des fruits
cultivés à l'extérieur du pays
si le produit est emballé au canada on
n'a pas l'obligation en tant que
qu'entreprise d'indiquer le pays de
rejet par garde aux aliments du québec
derrière
ne vous méprenez pas canada à ne
signifie pas qu'il s'agit de fruits
canadien c'est une norme de
classification de qualité plus
économique
les fruits imparfaite ont aussi fait
leur apparition au rayon des surgelés
c'est pas nécessairement parce que le
produit de moindre qualité cd produits
qui sont - intact d'une boule à fort
niveau de la découpe par exemple on
était d'épicerie ou choisi ce week-end
le profil je vais d'abord regarder le
quelqu'un spéciale si on a un désir
d'acheter un peu plus local on peut très
clairement sans aller par les produits
qui nous identifient xi on ne la fibre
biologique
donc on a des produits biologiques de
plus en plus qui sont offerts sur le
marché
par contre vous faudra payer le prix un
petit pouce
mais peu importe où s'arrête votre choix
les fruits surgelés held à réduire le
gaspillage alimentaire dans votre
congélateur
ils n'attendent plus que votre
créativité